be a good pick for both of these guys
and lisa if you guys are not aware it is
known to have some of the best movement
in the game really good sidewalk one of
the best back dashes in the game top
three for sure um but on the side of
kirakira you might think that eliza is a
very aggressive character one that is
very dangerous and close but her jump
back can can can make her a very strong
defensive character too so let's see
ladies and gents have you got
switzerland versus spain loser bracket
action here for top eight
yep same best of three format as well
that we've seen all day so far
and not a lot of chances to switch out
your character or anything like that
finishes the string okay kirakira
sitting here about even on the live lead
poking nobody wants to pull big moves
just yet until kirakira does it oh weird
access small hitboxes
there's rage
no it's not dead but uh very very close
here
okay
wow
okay a bit of a bit of a funny punish
there a combo oh oh when it hits
don't tell me he's gonna do the strand
sam don't tell him don't tell me
oh oh oh please go one more mix up
it's getting hot in here boys let's go
but early on there you see sandor like
you know he did he did challenge that
low you have to challenge it because
it's such a strong low if you don't try
to at least low power it once or twice
you know it's going to be free damage
yeah
okay chainsaws put back in here but it
took that second hit there it jails if
the first one hits you but uh not if
it's only the second one
yeah
okay
nice
kirakira looks poised and ready to take
this game with a big unblockable tech
setup
over the top two ships in the night
nice
conversion here
oh yeah yeah there it is gets that
unscaled ender takes the round
lane one
all right one around the knees here
chain's eyes here we go destruction mode
you know they're just testing testing
knowledges testing string knowledge you
know what what does he do when i do this
but the big barbarian
this is going to put lane in rage now
oh try to go for a little set up that
back one once again accounted but
doesn't commit to the full string rage
available now poking away nice down
forward one challenge and the down three
is going to seal the round kirakira one
round away from taking the first match
and again like i said he knows the
matchup he knows what he needs to do but
lane either way using that
that was only that was some ugly combo
there no then not what he wanted at all
power crush move
oh oh
nice go to the mid this time and he's
gonna burn the pizza is this gonna be
dead
i think it is
yeah
wow big on scale ender combo there
kirakira one of the players who all
you've definitely have to
bring to the side and have a word and
say hey man you're not using your meter
you're losing matches or winning them
with two bars a meter there kirakira and
showing today that uh you know that's
obviously a choice he wants to he's got
a savings account back there man that's
where he's storing all those bars you
know but uh he's cashing out today
ladies and gentlemen for the tekken
online challenge masters event here we
saw that there double bare burn to get
the extension onto the combo and take it
three rounds to one yeah it's just
really really solid stuff that he knows
the situation is okizemi is so important
guys to know your oki because not only
do you get big damage from your combo
but you're also able to put your
opponent into a mix-up right afterwards
which could lead to even more damage and
kirakira of course knows the inside out
um and i think that you know him having
played
at lisa um and got the character to a
really high rank recently i feel like
that's a really good way to learn how to
play against a character too right so he
knows the situation you saw the
punishment on things which are very
obscure with the chainsaw stuff and all
these different stances that lisa has he
knows what he needs to do here but
even even despite that lane kept it
close to sam so it's not over yet by any
means indeed we saw a couple of combo
drops and stuff uh
you know in that game and i'm
i mean i'm just gonna go ahead and say
it's just the top eight jitters you know
big tournament now you're you're placing
high and stuff and then isn't
you know uh one of the the kind of
staples in top eight so obviously he
hasn't played a lot at this super high
level i'm sure he absolutely can and but
we just need to see a little bit tighter
play if he wants to answer back against
kirakira
here we go back to the infinite as well
infinite azure and that was um that was
lane's pick right there so uh likes the
infinites obviously
um but here we go look at that man you
ever seen a river look as pretty
i heard this is based on like a real
place i don't know if there's any truth
in that but someone can tell me either
way we're back to the infinite stage and
again kirakira are definitely not going
to mind that one i did have a feeling
that this was going to be in favor of
both of the of the players so let's go
man no walls and play pure tekken i
guess kind of
kind of yeah
let's see if he can fix that combo yes
he can that's exactly what i wanted to
see on the lane
um this is now going to be a much much
closer match i'm sure
okay chainsaw stuff
doesn't need to do anything big
it's gonna be hard for elite for elias
to make this comeback when she hasn't
got the walls available uh but has got
the meter now let's see what you can do
goes for the the moonlight four here we
go we go tg combo right now
nice patience there get down blue stuff
spend
here girl looking down jab on what a
block on the moon glide four
yeah
and kira actually delayed that one as
well just in case lane ducked early but
then was one step ahead there so gets
the round
yes sir
okay
boom sending it
forward okay
yeah get out of the way of that you do
not want to get flipped up by that one
chainsaws here we go party time two
shines
looking for that ex dive
kick just kbd and out of there man he's
got the life lead he doesn't need to do
much here
expecting lowe's to come in
wow kirikou has just
taken back the life lead here
see what he can do with that
yeah let's the combo go early just to
get an okizemi situation where he could
guest for the win and kirakura got that
secures the round one round a piece now
here in the second game
and does know this match up you can see
it there good side step there in
destruction mode uh alisa is uh gains
access to a much much better side step
here but watch it two bars of meter now
oh oh oh nice lane here we go now one
round away from evening it up making the
comeback but two bars of me have full
resources for kira kira to work with
yeah
are we gonna see some of that big boy
stuff here
yeah maybe
okay not just yet hold on to him
all right
before with the jabs man instant dry
kick does not connect there's one of the
bars burned hop kick finds nothing but
air and there it is with a perfect
kirakira was one round away from losing
this game now it's even lane's got to be
feeling the pressure right now yeah and
then bar me if i care to work with the
closest set out here and eliminate lane
can you do it 4-4-4-2 brilliant punish
oh
why would you do that
okay two bars a meter again what were
you talking about about eliza's meter
but wait we should get up
a lot of damage
and the superman punched power crushed
there to finish it up we are one
match a piece here ladies and lads that
was really really solid stuff i had a
feeling that the the special getup was
going to come there because they hadn't
done it um in uh in the match so really
good stuff there from from uh from lane
but i've yeah one match a piece now this
is very back and forth i can't call it i
don't know who's gonna win this i wonder
if kira is going to choose to go to an
infinite
to a wall stage now because if he does
it's going to be the arena i don't know
if he wants to have walls in play but if
he does then the arena is the stage
we're going to be going to for this one
how much you see if i'm if i'm in
kirakira's shoes right now we started
the
game one on the infinite then
he had the choice to change it and he
changed it to a different infinite i
think if you're in kirakira's shoes you
want to make them as uncomfortable every
little inch is going to you know give
you that little advantage here at the
top eight of a masters tournament here i
would definitely go for the world stage
here um because clearly lane wants to
play on the infinites so i put him put
him out of his comfort zone or yeah yeah
perhaps yeah i mean because elisa
doesn't get like a lot with the walls
right the walls are not so significant
to her i know that kira likes to play
this sort of really defensive style with
eliza with jump jump backs and stuff but
he wasn't even doing that he wasn't
doing that with the in this match at all
like i feel like this tournament
specifically kira has decided to be a
lot more of an aggressive um eliza if so
if he wants to play that way maybe going
to the arena would be a good shot here
ladies let's see what he chooses to go
to and it's going to be the arena of
course how do you think i think it's a
good choice i think it's a really really
good choice because even if you want to
play on uh
on the infinite i mean and you know your
opponent does too i mean just just put
them you know if you don't mind give
yourself the advantage or your opponent
the disadvantage here look at this man i
ain't seen this look at all the fire
jets and stuff yeah do you know what i
missed though so i'm just a pac-man who
misses that man the the six uh dude the
the six sound tracking team
yeah man that was good that was good
bring it back
yeah
bring it back yeah all right let's go
kirakira off to a very quick start 10
seconds in already taking half life
yes sir
chainsaw time good blocks though
kirakira is uh sick of your chainsaws
man
okay sending forward okay
that's uh definitely around one there
for kirakira looking uh looking like he
just wants to put lane into a corner and
uh
kick him till he's dead and i like that
he committed to the background to the
full string now because he was getting a
lot of counter hits with just back one
did he commit to the two yeah
you want to see a bit more of that
just poking each other here oh defenses
oh are you serious
over the top two ships in the night
that's 13.
it's gonna get punished
punished from uh from lane beautiful
no doubt
no duck just yet
doesn't choose to burn the bar
yep okay watch out now working on a
second stick of butter here down in the
bottom right of your screen
just tons of lows there from both guys
but laying you know real and punishing
ford 442 really well it's a mix-up on
block if if he decides to go for the
meter or not but lane's been guessing
right every single time yeah
okay look at those two bars a meter here
we're expecting to see them come into
play here
down forward one how many was that roll
okay weird access stuff going on
down through the trains frame five kicks
oh wow answer is back with a hop kick
an odd odd response there oh yeah a
little damage here now lane has the life
lead but for how long
two bars a meter almost for kirakira
sending it for 23 seconds left on the
clock one bar is born goes for the moon
guy four oh nice
into the wall flips him over last chance
there
potential final round now for lane here
in this tournament we are still in the
losers bracket ladies and gentlemen
here we go
can kirakira close it out is then going
to go for the lows again he's attacking
the legs
okay a lot of lows
looking up more lows hop kick
shuts him right the way off yeah we
don't need to we don't need to block
loads top kick man yeah who needs it you
mean two passes oh boy here we go ladies
and gents it all comes down to this
final round
here we go
wow it's a gamble a lot on that doesn't
get the range there for the ending
though watch the bar it's gonna armor
through it but a big extp is gonna
answer back here
descending forward chopping those up
last chance here now for kirakira one
more what a block
okay no way there's no way he must come
back surely our burn
oh
with a comeback at the end with the slay
catch into rage art oh my god
if you're going to pull out that strat
that is the only time in the game where
you can do it
snake edge who expects that at this
level of tekken snake edge ragers
damn
kira kira you've just
you've made
everybody in the